hidden in turning red story about the
messiness of growing up are a ton of
secrets that predict the movie's big
twists and that godzilla-sized finale
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm explaining all the secret
symbolism details and clues in pixar's
latest hit spoilers ahead so take care
there are lots of signs early on in the
movie that by the end may well choose to
embrace her red panda spirit for example
when she transforms for the first time
she tries to hide the change she's
undergoing by wearing a hat to cover up
her new red hair but there are literally
signs everywhere telling her to be true
to herself it says be yourself on the
notice board right behind her friends
and the other words on the board like
loyal caring and fun neatly describe
may's ride or die mates and how they'll
later support her when they discover her
secret we love you mae you're our girl
yeah no matter what panda or no panda
there's also the dare to be different to
be you poster an encouragement that she
doesn't need to repress this strange new
panda version of herself then there's a
sign nothing changes if nothing changes
which hints at me upending her family's
tradition of locking away their panda
spirits and finally the dream big poster
also anticipates how in the end may will
decide to keep her fairy eight foot tall
side in her life when mae and her squad
perform a spontaneous version of four
towns nobody like you in the street
there's another hidden message this time
to awaken your potential dreams on top
of that the four-town flyer that abbey
shows may reveals that the name of the
band's tour is breaking free it's only
on screen for a split second but it's
another subtle suggestion that melin is
going to cut the apron strings and
become her own person and when she
high-fives red panda statue barton rubs
lisa's tummy it's a signal to how she'll
end up accepting both sides of her
identity
even before we learn the truth about
ming's own red panda transformation as a
young woman there's plenty of clever
clues that ready us for that reveal and
set up the big finale with may's mum
taking on her humongous panda form once
more and also their ancestor son ye
welcoming red panda may into the world
to begin with notice how both ming and
sun yi one by one appear in the shot as
mei tells us some of my moves are
also hers which emphasizes the crucial
panda connection between all three women
ming is also framed by two wooden
carvings of red pandas and in the altar
picture of sun yi there are two more red
pandas which emerge during may's
nightmare all of which points to both
the mother and daughter pandas in the
finale and also sun yi and mei's
appearance as red pandas right at the
end notice also how when they exit the
temple not only is ming standing next to
the much angrier looking statue of the
two a hint to the mingzilla version of
herself but if you look carefully you'll
also see that the statue on the left has
a young red panda under one of its paws
foreshadowing the jewel mother daughter
transformation an indication as to just
how dangerous ming's panda would become
was in the scar on maelyn's grandma's
face she and your grandma had a terrible
fight which you can still spot on
grandma's face when she turns into a
panda herself likewise red panda ming
has a similar hairstyle to her human
counterpart and the fact that there are
going to be even more red pandas in the
form of her aunties and grandma is also
signaled during may's nightmare when she
sees masses of them run over the roof of
the family temple by the way you can
literally see red panda faces hidden in
various accessories worn by mei's
aunties just as you can in ming's
pendant another clue to the final
showdown between mingzilla and maymay is
via the welcome mural that melin runs
past at the start of the film the wall
painting is of course in keeping with
the chinatown location however each
creature also represents one of the two
women the green one symbolizes ming
who's predominantly dressed in green
throughout the movie versus the orangey
red one which represents may and had
generally red clothing and much of
turning red is full of clever colour
symbolism that accentuates the
differences between mei and her mum red
and green are colours that contrast
sharply with one another so shades of
red are often used around may while
green is used for ming right down to
their nail varnish eye shadow and soles
of their shoes the color differences
emphasize the fact that melin isn't just
ming's mini-me she's her own distinct
person and they coming into her own as a
young adult is the movie's main theme
some people are like be careful honoring
your parents sounds great but if you
take it too far you might forget to
honor yourself intriguingly though both
mother and daughter also have just a
splash of the other's color in their
outfits mae has a green hair clip and
ming has a red pendant which signals
that despite their differences they're
still connected and it's also a clue to
the fact that they both have red panda
spirits another curious detail is that
although ming dislikes miriam because
she views her as a threat to her own
relationship with me
i mean she's a nice girl but maybe she's
slowing down both ming and miriam mostly
wear green a hint perhaps that while
they're different in many ways mei's mum
and friend have more in common than ming
would like to think as after all they
both love may and ultimately want the
best for her
may's grandma and aunties also favor
green emphasizing both their family
connection and the similarity between
ming and her own mother whose
relationship is also complicated by
feelings of perfectionism and not being
good enough something we also see
happening between may and ming
mirroring and symmetry is another
technique used to highlight the state of
may and ming's relationship we see this
first in the opening family snapshots
but also in the first scenes set at the
family temple you ready let's do this
may and ming even sweep in sync with one
another clean the red panda statues in
sync and after a long day sai and get up
in sync interestingly mink cleans the
statue with the more controlled calm
expression while mae's statue has more
of an animated or startled look
reflecting some of the feelings she'll
go through as she transforms after
falling out of sync for much of the film
as may grows into her own the mother
daughter symmetry and mirroring is back
again by the end after may helps ming
deal with her own issues of inadequacy
in relation to grandma
now if you'd like to discover even more
details hidden in turning red such as
all the pixar references to movies like
luca inside out coco lightyear and toy
story tap here to watch my turning red
easter eggs video there's also a link in
the video description so what do you
think of turning red and what were your
favorite moments in the movie let me
know in the comments below if you
enjoyed this then do like and share this
video i really appreciate it thanks for
enjoying this movie with me and hope you
have a marvellous movie loving week
yipikai movie lovers